I think one of our difficult
conditionings actually is that we feel
first of all over taught first of all
that we will feel better about ourselves
by demeaning others by putting others
down and I think a lot of workplaces
reflect that a lot of homes reflect that
you know that we we feel ok the way I am
gonna trust myself and feel good about
myself is if I can just kind of denounce
this other person and we asked I think
we actually feel terrible but we don't
realize it because we're so caught in
that paradigm if this is what we have to
do and so I would disrupt that first of
all and and really challenge that and we
also tend to think that compassion is a
weakness and that if we care we'll we'll
just burn out and you know compassion
will inevitably lead to exhaustion and
giving in losing a sense of principle
and discernment and and really having
boundaries and I think none of that is
true either we can redefine happiness so
that it's not just pleasure and endless
pleasure seeking and being superficial
or being like happy-go-lucky to having a
deep deep sense of resiliency and
connection to a bigger picture and we
would be a lot happier and success our
sense of what successes would follow
that when it comes to compassion I think
there always needs to be an examination
and balance it's a balance first of all
between compassion for ourselves and
compassion for others if we ignore
ourselves I mean that's not going to
work in the long run anyway we're not
gonna be able to sustain some effort
we're just going to burn out and it's
also a balance between compassion for
someone and discernment maybe we really
feel bad for someone and we need to be
strong we need to express disapproval we
really need to set a boundary that's
very clear not give them what they want
right and there's also balance between
having compassion
for someone and realizing I can't fix it
right I can't make your problem go away
I can be there I could try to help I
could do this I could do that but in the
end I can't control the unfolding of the
universe which I often add an addendum
to that like too bad right it's kind of
too bad but it's true
and so we need we need a balance in
order to have resiliency which is kind
of the secret ingredient in compassion
otherwise compassion becomes burnout it
becomes exhaustion